all right we're going to look at what
many of you wrote in over the last week
we're going to start with something that
is scary too much is it too much to call
this scary this is where we are right
now
Ray Wright commented on YouTube
I as well as every other Maga fan will
never vote for anyone else but for the
true president Donald Trump
he could be behind bars and we will
still vote for him Trump is the only one
that we can trust right now
this is a call
we know that this is a cult we've spoken
to cult experts we've spoken to
conspiracy experts we've spoken about
brainwashing we've put every expert
looks this up and down and says yes this
is a cult
but we also have to deal with the
political reality on the ground and so
when we see oh Tim Scott announced that
he's running
Tim Scott is somehow going to win a
Republican primary over Trump give me a
break
Ron DeSantis is trying to be like Trump
but be different than Trump
one aspect of why these guys don't
really have a shot
is because of them
the other aspect of why they don't have
a shot is because of people like Ray
Wright
Trump has assembled a cult of
personality around him that is unlike
listen it's I never like to say we've
never seen it in history no they're
they're over cult leaders and they have
cult followers that's not new
but in the modern American political era
there has never been a cult around an
elected official in the United States
the way we see around Donald Trump so
when Ray Wright says this stuff the true
president is Trump he could be behind
bars and I'll vote for him
believe them
because they're telling us the truth
and the question for us is how do we
ensure that Trump doesn't get another
four years the answer is quite simple
but making it happen
is another question let's look at some
other uh messages that came in the teen
gunsmith said Oh Boy on YouTube Don't
ban books in schools except for heavy
violence or sexual items like
genderqueer for example
now every time I see stuff like this I'm
of two minds on the one hand
the Bible has to be banned based on this
right I mean there's there's no way to
follow this guideline heavy violence and
sexual items
you you must ban the Bible from school
if you actually are going to be serious
about that but then I'm also reminded
that when you look at what materials
have been banned from schools it's often
just a completely unremarkable novel The
coming to age novel where the main
character or the author happened to be
LGBT
ban it okay and so yes they're
Hypocrites because the Bible is fine but
also their standards are extraordinarily
pathetic and it shows such a lack of
tolerance for anything other than what
they I guess now pretend school kids
need which is stories by heterosexual
writers about how great America is that
that seems to be the epitome of what
they want
um they truly can't handle any other
ideas any other identities any other
sort of content they are the very
snowflakes they claim that the left
actually is caddy lover says name one
law that has been passed that censors
that's not the right version of sensors
that censors the thing you are claiming
if you are referring to limiting
teachers from discussing topics like
gender
sexual orientation or the making up of
multiple pronouns with children in one
AR second or third grade
I would ask how are you okay with it I
don't even know what this person is
asking I I just it
it's it's clear they don't like the
left-wing perspective and they favor the
don't say Gable
but what I really need people to
understand is
when they talk about parents rights and
being heard at school-born meetings and
blah blah all this different stuff
this is the type of commentary they want
to hear at school board meetings they
want to turn the school board meeting
into a veritable circus Sideshow with
stuff like this
and that's exactly what they did during
the pandemic ERA with the masks and at
other times
and if they were to be in control
that's who would be in charge that
should scare every single one of us a
Florida son says say what you want about
his personality him being DeSantis
Florida has one of the best economies in
the U.S we're below average for Crime
both violent and property crime he
doesn't govern with his personality he's
not out to be a reality TV star he knows
how to get the job done that is what
should be important
a beautiful story
but it is only a story as I told you
before Florida doesn't have one of the
best economies in the U.S it's right
around 25th it's average you take any
state in the country there's a 50 50
shot that it has a better versus worse
economy than Florida Florida's economy
is totally middle of the road
Florida's crime rate totally middle of
the road it's not particularly good it's
not particularly bad Access to Health
Care in Florida very mediocre
infrastructure in Florida similarly
middle of the road and so the story of
this Florida success that DeSantis is
touring the country talking about if
it's examined even at all
it immediately becomes clear
Florida is right in the middle not a
particularly successful State not a
particularly unsuccessful State and then
the question becomes whether we think
that that record is worthy of a
presidential candidate Republicans will
have to answer that question first they
can decide are we impressed by the
Florida record of DeSantis enough to
make him the nominee instead of Donald
Trump
non-quack rodent
and said let me ask a question
should business owners be able to choose
whether or not they require masks but
not be completely controlled by the
state if they don't wish to bake a cake
for a gay wedding well it's a beautiful
uh analogy except that it is completely
nonsensical when in the United States we
talked about protected classes of people
in some states
LGBT identity gender identity sexual
orientation is a protected class
if indeed LGBT is a protected class then
discriminating against someone on that
basis would be against the law whereas
saying we have a policy here where
you've got to wear shoes or you've got
to wear a mask or whatever would be a
completely different category now I'm
not an unreasonable person if what
individuals are saying is there should
be no protected classes and everybody
should be allowed to do whatever they
want and say we don't want black people
in this store we don't allow Jewish
customers here or whatever if that's the
world that you want to to see well take
that position or take the position that
is on the opposite of that but don't
make this false analogy because we have
something called protected classes you
might not like that but it is the
reality and thus it makes the mask
versus gay wedding cake question a
completely irrelevant question under the
law now if you want the law changed by
all means go and advocate for that
Lynette posted on Facebook
if DeSantis was smart he would wait and
run in 2028 but he's too greedy and
narcissistic to play the long game and
we all know that he's not too smart I've
talked about this before on the one hand
I don't see a path for DeSantis to get
to 50 support in the Republican primary
which he needs to be the nominee so one
view would be
dude Trump's already got 55 60 percent
you can't win just wait it out run in
2028. the Counterpoint to that and I
understand this is most people most
Governors aren't polling 20 in the
Republican primary it's true most
Senators aren't pulling 20 in the
Republican primary so if you're Ron
DeSantis it could be difficult to look
at that polling and say 20 before I even
announce
I'm gonna wait four years
it's very difficult to do that it's sort
of like in poker when you flopped High
pair and you know you should probably
fold but you just can't quite get away
from it you want to see it through and
see how you do even if it cripples your
ability to run again in the future
um I think Lynette makes a good point
and I also see why DeSantis would not be
motivated by that
okay a bunch of commentary about the
Christopher key urine drinking interview
Baron Steuben posted this was an
incredibly insightful interview into how
trauma can affect the cognition of
otherwise reasonable individuals I
appreciate David's thoughtful handling
of this interview and not allowing it to
descend into a farce despite the
outrageous statements made by
Christopher it's important to understand
why these individuals think like this in
order to treat and prevent such
delusions agree 100
we really learned a lot about the sad
reality
of how Christopher key ended up
allegedly drinking and injecting urine I
will mention
I don't know that he was really drinking
urine I don't know that he really
injects urine and people wrote to me and
said do we really have proof that he's
actually drinking urine and not apple
juice and the answer is we really don't
we're taking him at his word
not necessarily the type of guy you want
to take at his word but okay a worker
bee from Wisconsin says I wish the media
would report gun injuries over deaths to
get a better picture of the Damage Done
by mass shootings and this is an
interesting point which says for example
the 2017 Las Vegas shooting had 60
deaths but over 400 gunshot injuries
with an additional 450 injuries from
fleeing danger how many of those 400
wounded victims are permanently disabled
or worse now it would be a nice it would
be nice to turn the narrative away from
Strictly mortality and include Serious
injury as well just reporting death
seems to minimize the Carnage for the
benefit of the gun lobby I believe that
this is a good point and I'm going to
make an effort to say killed
and injured as well we don't always have
completely accurate data on that but I
think that that is a good point and we
shouldn't understate I mean you know if
six people die but 80 are also in
hospitals some in critical condition
some serious Etc that is a hundred
percent part of the Damage Done by these
Mass Shooters and we shouldn't ignore
that so I'll try to do a better job
email info davidpackman.com if you have
something to say we will have a
fantastic bonus show for you today we
are off Monday Memorial day but it is
the day of our huge membership special
if you are interested in becoming a
member if you might want to become a
member and get all of the great member
benefits we offer
this Monday Memorial day we'll be
sending out an email in the morning
maybe 10 a.m seems like a good time
Eastern and it'll contain a coupon code
and instructions for signing up for a
membership at a comical discount comical
discount to be notified get on my
mailing list at davidpackman.com